لذلك وجدت دراسة حديثة في كلية الطب بجامعة هارفارد
أن الرجال الذين لديهم
وظائف شاقة لديهم في الواقع تركيزات أعلى من الحيوانات المنوية
وظائف شاقة مثل أنا فقط
سأفترض أن البث الصوتي ربما
لا شيء مثل هذا آسف ،
فهذه وظائف تتطلب
مجهودًا بدنيًا ثقيلًا وشاقة
لم يقتصر الأمر على أنهم اكتشفوا
أن نفس الرجال لديهم أيضًا
مستويات هرمون تستوستيرون أعلى من الرجال الذين
لا تنطوي وظائفهم على العمل البدني ، فقد
وجدت الدراسة أن الرجال الذين أبلغوا عن قيامهم
برفع الأحمال الثقيلة في العمل لديهم نسبة 46٪ أعلى من
تركيز الحيوانات المنوية و 44 عددًا إجماليًا أعلى
للحيوانات المنوية.  يبدو لي أن هذا
ربما يكون له علاقة بكمية
التمارين التي يمارسونها بشكل صحيح ،
ربما دعونا نلقي نظرة على سبب إجراء الدراسة
في المقام الأول
كجزء من دراسة إكلينيكية
تسمى الأرض والتي تعني
الصحة البيئية والإنجابية
هي في الواقع تعاون بين
كلية هارفارد تي إتش تشان للصحة العامة
والكتلة العامة التي تم تشكيلها
لدراسة الصحة الإنجابية من خلال
عدسة المواد الكيميائية البيئية
وخيارات نمط الحياة والشيء هو أنها
دراسة مهمة بشكل لا يصدق لأن الحيوانات المنوية لدى
الرجال تهم و  كانت معدلات الخصوبة
في حالة سقوط حر على مدار الخمسين
عامًا الماضية ، يا فتى أه نحن متجهون لبعض
الأطفال من الرجال اكتب هلسكوبي بائس
هنا
أه ليس في أي وقت قريب على
الأرجح ولكن الحقائق تنذر بالخطر بعض
الدراسات بما في ذلك دراسة للدكتورة شونا سوان
أظهرت انخفاضًا بمقدار 50 نقطة  في عدد الحيوانات المنوية
منذ سبعينيات القرن الماضي وبحسب بعض الأرقام ،
تنخفض مستويات هرمون التستوستيرون بنسبة تصل
إلى واحد في المائة سنويًا ، لكن هذا ليس
كل ما توصلت إليه دراسة الأرض أن
جودة تعداد الحيوانات المنوية انخفضت بنسبة تصل إلى 42
بين عامي 2000 و 2017 وحدها ،
وخصوبة التستوستيرون.
لذا ، ما الذي يحدث هنا كما تعلم ،
يرجى الرجوع إلى سؤالي السابق
حول الواقع المرير المستقبلي ،
لذا لا يعرف الباحثون ،
وهذا نوع من أسباب
هذه الدراسة هي المواد الكيميائية البيئية التي
تسبب هذا التراجع ، قد تكون
خيارات نمط الحياة أو ربما هناك بعض
قضية الصحة العامة الأوسع مثل
زيادة مستويات الأمراض المزمنة أو
كل ما سبق ، لكن ما
تقوله حقًا هو أنه من أجل إنقاذ
البشرية ، أحتاج إلى الحصول على وظيفة
كرجل إطفاء أو حطاب ،
لقد كان لديك حقًا  لا يوجد
سبب حسنًا ، حسنًا ، يعلم العلماء بالفعل
أن التمرين يرتبط
بصحة إنجابية أفضل ، حسنًا ، لذا فهي ليست
الوظيفة ، إنها التمرين الذي يمارسونه
ربما وهذا يوضح
الطبيعة المثيرة للدراسات القائمة على الملاحظة
مثل هذه الدراسة التي يمكنهم رؤيتها
الاتجاهات لكنها  يصعب فهم
السببية لجعل الأمور أكثر
تعقيدًا ، كان العديد من
المشاركين في الدراسات رجالًا كانوا يبحثون عن
العلاج في مركز الخصوبة ، مما
قد يعني أن النتائج لن
تترجم إلى عدد أكبر من السكان ، ما
يعرفونه هو أن اتخاذ
خيارات صحية مثل مشاهدة ما  إن تناولك
للكثير من التمارين سيؤدي إلى
صحة أفضل مما سيؤدي إلى
صحة إنجابية أفضل ، فقد يكون
الوحي الحقيقي هنا ليس أن
الرجال الذين لديهم وظائف تتطلب جهداً بدنياً
لديهم عدد أكبر من الحيوانات المنوية ، بل أن الرجال الذين
لديهم وظائف مستقرة لديهم  انخفاض عدد الحيوانات المنوية ومستويات
هرمون التستوستيرون
جيدًا ، أعتقد أنني ما زلت أريد نوعًا ما أن أكون
حطابًا
حقًا ، فأنت حقًا مضبوط على ذلك ،
لماذا لا تذهب فقط إلى صالة الألعاب الرياضية ، ربما
صالة رياضية بها تقطيع الخشب بدلاً من
مجرد رفع الأثقال